Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Bethenny Frankel,
founder of the game‐changing
mega‐brand Skinnygirl,
joins the tank.
It's a good product,
and I think that's totally lost
in the message.
Both: Aah!
I think it's a little too edgy.
‐No worries, girlfriend.
‐No!
I haven't been in bed
with so many billionaires
in at least a couple of weeks.
‐Aah!
We're the parents
to five kids.
‐Oh.
‐Both: Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
My partner and I
have invested $1.2 million.
‐Your valuation is nuts.
‐Nuts.
Are you in or out?
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a product that comes to
the aid of hairy situations.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Jennifer.
And I'm Gita.
We're from Los Angeles,
California,
and our company
is called No Mo‐Stache.
We are seeking $100,000
for 25% equity.
No Mo‐Stache is revolutionizing
every woman's beauty routine.
Ladies, have you
ever been driving
to an important business
meeting, and...
Both: Aah!
...notice a glistening, hairy
lip in the rearview mirror?
Or what about you,
busy moms,
juggling a million
things at once,
and when you finally get a
chance to look in the mirror...
Both: Aah!
...you need a wax!
No Mo‐Stache has all of these
hairy situations handled.
They are mess‐free
cold‐wax strips,
so there is no risk of burning
your skin with hot, gooey wax.
Curious how it works?
We thought you would be.
So first, rub the strip in your
hands to heat the wax up.
It's that easy.
Then pull the strip apart
and apply it
to the side of your face.
Rub back and forth for hair
to adhere to the wax.
Hold skin taut,
and pull opposite
of hair growth.
‐Aah!
Herjavec:
She's not smiling anymore.
Frankel: She's smiling!
She's smiling.
No Mo‐Stache is the only
waxing kit on the market
that is packaged
for your convenience
in a small, discreet tin,
giving you the freedom
to wax any time, any place.
Throw a No‐Mo in your bag,
and always be prepared.
When you have No Mo‐Stache,
you have no mo' worries.
Both: So, Sharks, who's ready
to get in with smooth skin?
‐I need to ask a very ‐‐
‐Do we get samples?
I need to ask a very,
very important question.
We have some samples.
If you get
that extra hair,
why don't you just
shave like the rest of us?
‐What?!
‐Oh, no!
You take a little razor
and go badabing, badaboom,
and it's gone.
‐No, it would grow in.
It would grow in.
You would have a Chia Pet
on your lip
by a week from Tuesday.
‐No.
Have you ever tried it?
Then you don't know.
‐Excuse my ignorance.
‐Uh‐huh.
Is this that big a problem?
Is there that many women
that have mustaches?
‐Oh, my God.
‐Everybody has a mustache.
‐Everybody.
‐Really?
Let me ask you a question.
What's the difference between
this and the Sally Hansen strips
that you carry in your purse?
Perfect,
perfect example.
You could carry it
in your purse,
and somebody could see it
when you open up your bag.
And then they'll be
like, "Girl, why do you
have the Sally Hansens?"
Sorry, I don't know what
a Sally Hansen strip is.
It's the waxing people.
They have a business
of hair removal.
A bunch of people do.
‐Yeah, they're beauty ‐‐
But this is a tin.
Their concept here
is discretion.
This is a tin. It's like putting
a tampon in a single container.
There's nothing
proprietary about this?
‐No.
It is the only portable
waxing kit on the market.
Is it patented in some way?
No. You can't
patent the tin.
So what are
you bringing here?
What do you've got
that worth anything?
‐I have no idea.
‐It's portable.
It's portable.
I have 14 years of waxing
experience as a beautician.
‐That's worth $400,000?
‐The proof is in the sales.
Right?
Tell us what it costs you
to make, what you sell it for,
where you sell it,
and how much you've sold.
Our cost of goods
is $1.74 landed.
‐The whole kit.
‐The whole kit sent here.
We've done $400,000
in sales...
‐What?!
‐Cuban: There you go.
...in two years, yeah.
How much this year
are you going to do?
$300,000 this year.
Last year we sold ‐‐
‐What does it sell for?
I'm sorry.
‐It's $18 retail.
That one little tin is $18?
‐It's 12 wax services.
‐12 wax strips.
So there you go, Bethenny.
‐Listen.
‐Ba‐bam!
I really do think
this is a gimmick.
It's what you buy on the way out
of, like, the lingerie store.
‐It's a $400,000 gimmick.
‐So, wait.
So where are you selling it?
‐I don't get it.
So, we're currently
selling at Sephora.
We're in the checkout
beauty on the go, in the bins,
the impulse bins.
‐Wow.
‐That's beautiful.
‐Yes.
Cuban: Gita, how did you
get in there?
So, we got our product
in Real Simple magazine.
And then one day, our e‐mail
just kept going bonkers.
And I'm like,
"What is going on?"
And just order after
order after order.
And yet, there's nothing
proprietary but what's in here.
But you know what?
Convenience sells.
There's nothing proprietary
about water, either.
‐Yes.
‐Are you in every Sephora?
‐No, we're in 60 Sephoras.
‐No, we're not.
‐60. How many are there, total?
‐Yes.
‐Remind me.
‐200.
‐Can you get the other stores?
‐Why do you think
they haven't
taken you into the others?
Originally, we were in the other
stores, in 200 stores.
And now we're in 60 stores.
‐Okay.
‐They reduced?
So the sales weren't good
in some of those places?
Actually, that's not true.
Every single week,
the sales were consistent.
‐Then why?
They wanted to bring ‐‐
make room for new trends.
That happens, right?
They roll through things.
‐Yeah, it's ‐‐
‐Well, so that's a little bit
of a concern
'cause this may not be ‐‐
If it was selling really
well, they would've kept it.
Right?
‐I mean ‐‐
It's hard to defend the fact
that you lost 140 stores.
That's what basically
happened, right?
Yes.
But I've had so many products
that have gone into all doors,
and then they do take it down ‐‐
‐Well, tell me why ‐‐
Tell me why
that's exciting news.
Well, what's exciting news
is that since then,
we have been pushing
the pedal to the metal
to not have all
of our eggs in one basket.
‐In the Sephora basket.
‐Both: Exactly.
That's it.
So basically, it's a marketing
play on an old commodity.
And you've done a good job in
getting some shelf space for it.
Hopefully, you're going
to diversify your sales
outside of just
one distributor.
Yes.
We are launching with five
more distributors in September.
Oh, it came off.
It did.
I want to say
something positive.
I just waxed Mark's arm,
which I never thought
I'd say in this lifetime.
‐You did?
So, all the competitors
that I have used in the past,
they are very sticky.
They get gooey.
They get all over everything.
‐Yeah.
They're still on there later,
and you're feeling it.
I just waxed his arm,
and it's very neat.
Now that Mark has been waxed,
that changes everything.
So I'm going to
make you an offer.
‐Yeah.
‐You ready?
You're asking $100,000 for 25%.
You're very lucky
to be here today.
I might say that, too.
‐Yeah.
Because I'm willing to give you
the $100,000 for 10%.
Wow.
But the way you're
going to pay me back
is I'm going
to get $1 a lip.
That's the way I like
to look at it.
‐A lip?
‐A dollar a lip?
Every time you sell
one of these ‐‐
Excuse me, silence
while I get the offer out.
I'm going to give you
$100,000 for 10% equity.
But every time you sell
one of these,
I get $1
until I receive $300,000 back.
And then, it goes away.
I don't normally say this,
but that's a good deal.
That's not a bad offer,
shockingly.
It actually is a great offer.
Here's the thing.
I have thought about ‐‐
You're very attached
to the name.
I think it very much
limits you to only hair removal.
And I've thought that there
needs to be a kit for women
that has nipple covers...
‐Yes.
...your sticky tape,
your hair removal thing.
‐Yes.
‐This is one little gimmick.
No disrespect. This is going to
go away in a minute.
No.
How large is
the nipple‐cover market?
The nipple ‐‐
I have a female audience.
I have thought that places
like Sephora need a girl's kit.
Yes.
A whole kit with
all of these things.
So...
‐I need to own that market.
...you are asking
$100,000 for 25%.
I would give you
$100,000 for 40%.
‐Oh.
‐But you have me.
‐Oh!
‐Oh.
And we're going to create
a brand of fashion...
All of a sudden,
there's no headlights!
...and beauty of a kit
for women.
A Skinnygirl solutions kit.
This is one little product.
I ‐‐ There's a million types
of hair removal.
That's savage.
You're going to be dead
in the water.
You had one retailer, and you
already reduced by 140 stores.
You need to do
a female solution.
You have to re‐brand it
under Bethenny's name.
‐40%?
‐Yeah!
You must be kidding.
‐It's 40% of something.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Jennifer and Gita have
two offers on the table
from Kevin and Bethenny
for their hair‐removal kit,
No Mo‐Stache.
But Bethenny's offer
would require them
to re‐brand their product
under Bethenny's
Skinnygirl brand.
Ladies, do you want to go
down that direction?
Do you want to give up
your company under her brand?
You don't want to build
somebody else's business.
You do not.
You want to build
your business.
You do not.
You have a great idea here.
I don't think that's a bad
idea, actually.
Whoa!
It's a very competitive space.
So, I was sitting here ‐‐
You could sell it on QVC!
You could come in with me.
No one has put it together
in a compact way.
You're going away
for a girls' weekend.
You're going to a wedding.
You don't know what's
going to happen, not
until you get dressed.
‐It's like your emergency kit.
‐If your strapless dress
is falling down ‐‐
Yes.
‐You have made an offer for 40%.
‐To help a woman in a pinch.
All right, what are you
doing, Lori?
‐I kind of like this idea...
‐What are you doing?
...because I think
that we could sell it.
Me too.
So where were you at,
$100,000 for 40%?
‐Yes.
‐Oh, savage!
‐That is savage.
‐That's crazy!
What are you
going to do with ‐‐
‐Listen, listen!
‐I am absolutely the person.
‐The two of us ‐‐
‐And you're allowed to counter.
‐That's savage, savage.
‐We're allowed to counter.
‐Don't do that deal.
‐You've got us, though,
two power bitches.
‐Savage?
Jennifer, let me
ask you a question.
I just want to be clear.
Bethenny's offer is she wants
to re‐brand your company...
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐...under her company name.
Or ‐‐ Or what Lori and I decide
together, if we're partners.
I don't have a problem with
the individual items' names.
I think they're cute.
No. By the way ‐‐
Good point ‐‐
That SKU should have that
name, and the others, too.
And No Mo‐Bad Breath,
or whatever you want
to come up with.
You guys can be creative.
‐I like that.
‐No Mo‐Bad Breath.
‐Whatever, but the whole kit
is called something
that we come up with.
So No‐Mo everything.
Listen, ladies.
‐You don't have to re‐‐
‐No Mo‐Blister.
No Mo‐Stache, No Mo‐Mark.
I'm out.
I can get access to a Chihuahua
with no hair,
and we could stick it
right on the tin.
You won't
have to pay anything.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, I'm changing something.
Aah!
We could call the whole brand
No‐Mo, but it's no more,
and you figure out
what all the problems are.
Yeah.
No Mo‐Nipple,
No Mo‐Panty Lines.
‐We have a lot of those, too.
‐Honestly, I love this.
So it's your brand,
but it's our solution.
I don't want you to do all this.
I just want to give you money.
‐I love the No‐Mo name.
‐I like the No‐Mo name, too.
The No‐Mo name
is really clever.
As much as profit
is genderless,
I just feel like this is
a brand to empower women.
And I feel like you guys
get the vision.
Wait a minute.
So our counter would
be then, 35%.
Two Sharks, 35%.
Well, you guys came in
at $100,000 for 25%, right?
Mm‐hmm.
Which tells me that
you really want partners.
What you get along with us is a
lot of credibility and branding.
Why do so much?
But you couldn't have
better partners.
I'm only asking for 10%.
Let me make it even
more interesting for you.
I'll drop my royalty
down to 75 cents.
You can't get into
business with him.
You could not pick two
better women.
Absolutely. You do not have to
give up that much equity.
‐What was your counter?
‐It's a lot of equity.
If you would be willing to do
a deal where we'd stay back
to the 25% equity,
and then there was a royalty,
we'd be open to that, as well.
We just have
our hearts set.
Okay, I'm going to make it
more interesting
'cause I want to squeeze
their heads a little bit.
I'm going to drop my royalty
down to 50 cents, okay?
Not $1 anymore, it's 50 cents.
‐Ooh!
And I'm only taking 10%
of the company.
Forget these guys.
What are you waiting for?
Let's do the deal.
‐Okay, we're being creative.
‐Okay.
We'll go to the 35%,
Bethenny and I,
$100,000 with a $1 royalty...
‐O'Leary: Oh, that's outrageous!
‐...that we'll split,
that we'll split...
‐It's already down to 50 cents.
...on each kit of
No‐Mo everything
until we get our money back,
and then, we'll cut the royalty.
My deal's way better,
way better.
You do deals like
that all the time.
You're giving up
too much equity.
If this works, you've given
away your company now.
♪♪
Would you be willing
to go up to $200,000
and the royalties,
and then go back down to 25%?
I'll take that deal.
No, we'll take that deal.
And No‐Mo negotiating.
‐There you go.
‐[ Both screaming ]
Oh, my God!
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Wow.
‐Congrats, girls.
‐Thank you, ladies.
Congratulations, ladies.
‐Oh, my God.
‐It's like our dream.
Like, we wanted the strongest
women in the Tank.
‐Exactly what we wanted.
‐Like, oh, my God.
I'm freaking out.
You have no creativity
in structuring deals.
‐Well, that ‐‐
‐You're just ripping me off.
‐That's why Mark's here.
‐[ Laughs ]
Learn, Grasshopper,
learn.
I'll wax your back
as a thank‐you.
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a product
designed to make caring
for a baby easier and cleaner.
♪♪
Aww.
Hello, Sharks!
I'm Mike.
And I'm Amy.
And this is
10‐month‐old Emmett.
We are here from Albany,
Oregon, seeking $85,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company, SnoofyBee.
We're the parents
to five kids.
‐Oh, what?
‐Five kids, yes.
My favorite thing
about being a dad
is watching that
beautiful curiosity
my kids have for
the world around them.
But unfortunately, there's no
off switch for that curiosity
when you have a really
nasty diaper to change.
Those cute little hands, they
can start reaching and grabbing
at the absolute
worst times.
And that's how we came up with
the clean‐hands changing pad.
Our portable changing station
is the first of its kind
to gently redirect
your child's curiosity,
keeping their hands
happily away from the mess.
You can hang toys from the sides
to make diaper time extra fun.
‐Clever.
‐Or...
‐Smart.
‐Yeah.
...you can lay it flat
like a large, traditional
changing pad.
It has a foam pillow inside
so it's comfortable
to use anywhere,
and its water‐resistant surface
wipes clean in seconds.
So, Sharks,
with your expertise
and a little bit
of your capital,
we can get the Clean Hands
Changing Pad
on the shelves
across the world.
Do we get samples?
‐Yes!
‐Exactly.
‐We'll take the baby.
‐All right.
So, Emmett's going to help
pass out these things.
Good job, Emmett.
‐He's cute.
‐Aww.
‐Hi!
‐He's a shy guy.
He loves people
from a distance,
but he gets a little shy
sometimes up close.
‐Hello!
‐Oh!
Robert, go ahead
and change his diaper.
All right, we'll pass
the baby down.
We'll pass the baby along.
Thank you.
‐There you go.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐Hey!
‐Oh, my God.
I want to take the baby.
You all ‐‐ You have five.
You could spare one.
‐Oh, wait.
‐Lori's scaring the baby.
Aww!
Hey, no worries.
Well, it actually
is his nap time.
‐Aww.
‐It is.
Kevin's, too,
but we keep him up.
Well, he's been
awesome so far.
But we're going to pass him
out to Grandma
'cause we don't want
to push our luck.
‐Not today.
‐I'll be right back.
‐Bye!
‐Bye, Emmett.
So, Sharks, which one of you
wants to join us
to turn stressful,
messy diaper time
into fun, clean play time
for babies everywhere?
It's really clever.
I've never seen anything that...
What's proprietary here?
We're patent‐pending
on the ‐‐
We call it the
redirection barrier,
that goes around the child
as you're changing him.
So utility patent?
Yeah, we have
a utility patent pending.
When do you think
you'll get it?
It'll probably still be
another year or so.
Wow.
Guys, can you tell us
your background?
So, we have no, like,
business experience.
I sold shampoo
before I met him.
I was in sales
for nine years.
Yeah.
What were you selling?
What did you sell?
I was selling
freight logistics.
What made you want
to start the business?
Well, when we had
this idea,
we made a rough prototype
for one of our sons.
And we took it out
at a party one day,
and we got a lot
of reaction from people.
We were just changing our
own kid's diaper.
So we did
an initial test run.
We saw there was
good reaction from people,
so we launched
on Kickstarter.
We had a huge success there.
‐How much were you asking?
How much did you ask for,
how much did you get?
We were asking for 10,000.
We got 120,000.
‐Wow.
You sold 120,000
on Kickstarter.
‐Yeah.
‐Did you ship all that?
So ‐‐ So, that's
a very interesting story.
Do you want to take that,
Amy?
Sure.
So, we got 10,000 units in
and we opened up
our containers,
and that's when we realized
30% is not finished.
Where was it being
manufactured?
‐Oh, my God.
‐It was overseas.
But what happened next?
'Cause the key is
what you did next.
So, that's when
I actually quit my job.
We have
a 1,500‐square‐foot house.
We...
There was six people
living in it at a time,
and I was pregnant
with our son.
‐Wow.
‐We overhauled our house.
Yeah.
We got a bunch of friends
and family to inspect,
and we hired
some people to sew.
So, what do you want to do
with this product?
What's the plan with ‐‐ If I
give you the $85,000 ‐‐
Well, how 'bout what have they
been doing with the product?
What have you sold,
and where are you selling it?
All right. So, we've been doing
this for just about two years,
and our total sales
are $700,000 in revenue.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow.
‐$700,000?
‐That's great.
‐What have you done ‐‐
‐And raising five kids.
What have you done
this year to date?
So, our first year
we did $140,000.
Last year,
we did $400,000.
This year, we're projected
to hit over $650,000.
Where did you sell that?
We sold that online on our
own website and on Amazon.
Have you tried
any retailers?
So, we're planning on going
to the baby show...
You haven't ever
been there before?
We haven't ‐‐
We haven't visited there yet.
Wow.
You're doing $700,000,
and you've hit the trade show?
And why isn't this
in buybuy Baby
or, like, real, like,
baby retailers?
This issue we had with
our manufacturing
in the beginning really set
us back with our cash flow.
Hmm.
And if we're going
to get into retail,
we need help
from someone like you.
So, now much do one
of these cost?
What do you sell them for,
and what do they cost to make?
So, we got the price down
to about $6 per unit.
‐Wow.
‐$6 per unit?
And what are you
selling it for?
We sell it for $29.99
on our website.
People will spend
anything on babies.
How much did you spend
on marketing last year
for online ads?
‐Yes.
So, our marketing was about
40% of revenue last year.
Ooh.
So it was about
100‐something thousand.
Did you make any money
last year?
Yes, we did.
So, we've been paying
ourselves a little bit
because we need
to pay the bills.
We take out about
$4,000 a month,
and we have that pay
for our seven.
But you know what, guys?
You guys deserve
a ton of credit.
‐Yeah.
You've done
a much better job
than people that come out
with MBAs and the rest.
So I can't applaud
you enough.
But even though
it's a great idea,
I think marketing it is going
to be harder than you imagine.
That's why you're spending
40% of your revenue.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐I think you can get innovative,
but I think it's a lot more
challenging than you realize.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐Sure, Mark. Thank you.
‐Yeah, thank you.
‐Congrats, though.
Thank you.
I like you guys.
I think it's phenomenal.
I think you are true
entrepreneurs.
But I like products
that you buy often
and always that you keep ‐‐
you know, consumables or
products that you keep buying.
And I'm scared of it just being
one SKU that you buy once.
So for that reason, I'm out.
‐Well, thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
You know, I look at this
as a product, not a business.
The only way I'd do
this deal is if ‐‐
It would have to have
this huge contingency
on the patent being issued.
Because I want to take this
and license it
to a large manufacturer
that already has logistics,
manufacturing, marketing,
and a customer base.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐My offer's this.
I'll give you the $85,000
for 20%...
Ooh.
Wow.
...contingent on the patent
being issued.
And then, you have to agree,
although you'll control it,
to take a license deal.
So now, you would be
okay with us
still selling
this product on our own.
‐Of course.
‐You shouldn't license it
because you've built
a real business.
‐I disagree.
‐I disagree with you completely.
What are you going
to do, Robert?
So, love you guys.
My challenge is a little bit
about the single product.
You're very good
with finding needs.
I'd like to see you
expand the products.
I think ‐‐ I think you're going
to need a little more money.
I'd like to see some of
the money be used maybe
for some more product
development, that kind of stuff.
Keep going with the online ads.
[ Sighs ]
I'll give you $125,000
for ‐‐
for 15%.
$125,000 for 15%.
Greiner: All right.
What's really cool is
I've never seen anything
like this.
It fits into my family
of products.
We have our own special section
in buybuy Baby.
So I do feel
I am your perfect partner.
I think you could use
a little bit more money.
I'm going to go
$100,000 for 20%,
and I will help you to finance
all the big orders that
we're going to be getting.
All the offers ‐‐
We love funding orders.
Okay.
So I think that goes
without saying.
♪♪
Lori, we would like
to make a counter to that.
We would like to have
a valuation of around $600,000.
So our counter is
$120,000 for 20%.
♪♪
Done.
‐Okay.
‐Oh, my gosh!
Let's do it!
Congratulations, guys.
Oh, you guys are so smart.
Thank you.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐Good job.
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐You're smart.
‐Congrats.
Lori is the one Shark,
we were really hoping
we could pique her interest
because we know
that she's a perfect fit
for what we have going on.
Honestly, like, giving
natural childbirth
was probably easier
than what I just did.
But I am so proud of Mike
and all of the hard work
that he's done
for our family.
He's awesome.
Oh, my gosh.
You know what I loved
about them the most,
is no fancy schooling,
no venture capital...
‐They just figured it out.
They just figured it out.
If they could do it from Albany,
Oregon, anybody can do it.
Yeah.
♪♪
I was born in Queens, New York.
I had a stepfather
who was a horse trainer,
so I spent a lot of time
at the racetrack.
Now that I think about it,
spending a lot of time
at the racetrack
prepared me for business.
I mean, business is
about the hustle.
And I grew up around the hustle.
I always had an inclination
towards health,
but also a love of food.
I eventually went
to culinary school.
So that how I became
a Natural Foods chef.
Then I created bethenny bakes.
Bethenny bakes were
ahead of their time.
They were wheat, egg,
and dairy‐free cookies
long before it was popular.
And that's when "Martha Stewart:
The Apprentice" came along.
I was a runner‐up
on "The Apprentice."
Didn't get that job,
which I really wanted.
I'm a person that believes,
get on the road
and you can get derailed,
but you just are moving forward.
So every experience led me
to the next experience.
Years later in the Hamptons,
this woman approached me.
She said, "We're doing a show
called 'The Housewives.'"
Everybody was worried about
showing how rich they are,
buying diamonds,
and getting facials.
I was on that show
for one reason ‐‐
use it as a platform.
Through "Housewives," the
Skinnygirl margarita was born.
I created a new category
that had never existed before.
I was the first low‐calorie
cocktail in history.
Then I partnered
with Beam Suntory,
the top‐four liquor
company in the world.
But I maintained Skinnygirl
in all other categories ‐‐
Skinnygirl candy, salad
dressings, microwave popcorn.
I went from having no money
to having a lot of money.
I'm sure there will be
a lot of skepticism
about why I'm a Shark.
But I'm a Shark because
I'm a great businesswoman
who created an international
brand from zero.
Morning!
People may know me
as a reality star,
but I've always been
an entrepreneur.
I want to be a Shark because
I want to inspire entrepreneurs.
I love hearing ideas,
giving people advice.
This is going to be
something I devour.
I love that.
I really can relate to those
entrepreneurs
walking in the door
because it wasn't so long ago
that I was hustling my idea,
trying to sell it,
trying to get anybody
to believe in me.
And everyone was telling me no.
I think I'm different
because I speak
to a young demographic of women
who want to be businesspeople.
And I want women to know that
it is the most empowering thing
to make your own money
and execute your own ideas.
I'm living proof
of entrepreneurship.
I have done it from nothing.
And so now, it's my turn
to help other people.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a technology
to enhance an important
step in good health.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Randall Redfield.
I'm the founder of dreampad.
I'm here today seeking $800,000
in return
for 10% of my business.
[ Coughing ]
America has a big sleep problem.
Poor sleep today
is so widespread,
it's considered an epidemic.
How cool would it be
if there was a device
that could improve
your ability to relax,
a device you simply
lay your head on
and it could calm your body
and stop your mind from racing
while you're trying to sleep?
Well, that device is here.
I'm happy to introduce
the dreampad ‐‐
a music pillow that reduces
stress and improves sleep.
Music flows from
within the dreampad
directly to your inner ear,
and that process triggers
your body's relaxation response.
Could I get a volunteer
to come up and experience it?
‐I would, sure.
‐Can we both?
Thank you, Mark.
Sure.
Frankel: I'm so jealous.
‐No cuddling here, please.
‐All right, no cuddling.
‐Okay.
‐Oh, I can hear it.
Are they listening
to something right now?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's very soft,
new‐agey music.
Music from the dreampad
is audible
only to the person
whose head is on it.
Even someone lying two feet away
on the same bed
can't hear a thing.
[ Giggling ]
‐I'm diving right in.
‐Take a jump.
‐What are we listening to?
‐All right.
Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
It's amazing.
This is good.
You can hear it
on both sides.
It should go through
most of the pillow.
It's just usually used
in a very quiet room.
‐That's good.
‐Not bad.
Herjavec: Was that good for you
too, Bethenny?
I haven't been in bed
with so many billionaires
in at least
a couple of weeks.
Okay, Robert.
If you would grab that one here.
I'll go and grab
Lori's, too.
Thank you, Robert.
Is it a feather pillow?
What is it?
There are four
different models.
Two of them are faux feather,
and we have one thin one,
and another one
is in memory foam.
Thank you.
Where's the speaker?
‐There's no speaker.
It's a transducer that plays
music through vibration.
So a speaker, typically,
the sound goes out
through the airwaves.
And with the dreampad
transducers,
it goes out internally.
Oh, wow!
It's really nice.
‐I'm obsessed.
‐[ Snoring ]
Let me explain to you
the way it works.
You download the app
to your phone,
and you can either
play it wirelessly
to the dreampad by connecting
a little wire receiver.
Wow, it's amazing!
So basically, you would
pair this with your phone.
‐Right.
‐Plug it into the dreampad.
There's a little pocket
on the side.
And then you can play music
from your phone.
The dreampad comes with an app
that has ten music
choices on it,
so we've constructed
specific music for sleeping.
You can use your own music
if you want.
My whole entire life, I've
suffered from lack of sleep.
‐Okay.
‐I cannot sleep.
So I have a sound machine.
I have the aromatherapy
going in my room.
Right.
What if I put a sound machine
right next to the pillow?
What is the difference,
honestly?
This is doing something
completely different
than the sound
machine's doing.
The sound machine is
giving you a white noise
that's coming
through the airwaves
that's blocking out
other noise in the room.
‐Okay.
‐And they help.
They're perfectly fine.
‐Okay.
The dreampad's doing something
entirely different.
When you put your head on it,
the vibration from the pillow
is going actually through
your body to your inner ear.
So it's the music
and the vibration.
Exactly.
The music is the vibration.
They're the same.
I'll tell you what's keeping me
awake on this deal...
‐Wow.
‐...is this $800,000 for 10%.
‐Well, don't go there yet.
‐I have to go there.
Don't go there yet!
I understand the product.
Let me first explain
how it works.
It's a speaker in a pillow
for $8 million.
‐No!
‐It's not a speaker,
and it's not a pillow.
‐Got it. I love the schtick.
‐It's not a pillow.
‐It's $8 million.
It's a lot more than a pillow.
You don't sell it
as a pillow?
If you call it a pillow, people
aren't used to paying
more
than $20, $30, $40.
What does it cost?
The pillow is $159, average.
That's a lot for a pillow.
‐Right.
So that's why I'm saying
it's really a relaxation tool.
My trouble with it,
and we've got to get
back to deal with this
because we're in the Shark Tank,
and you're asking for
$800,000 for 10%.
That's $8 million valuation.
Well, I think it's
an amazing opportunity
for the following reasons.
‐Oh, really?
‐Yeah.
It's a sleep product
which is addressing
over a third
of the population.
Support that, other than just
saying it helps people sleep.
Show Mr. Wonderful
the money.
We've got $600,000 in sales
since we launched last November.
Okay.
What are you going to make
in cash flow this year
that would want or entice me
to give you $800,000?
Our projections
for the year are $1.2 million.
Okay, what are you
going to make on that?
Oh, our profit on that
will be roughly $150,000.
We really didn't even
talk about your cost.
We have a 65% margin
on the product.
‐65% margin.
‐But where are those
$1.2 million in sales
coming from?
A combination of Amazon,
direct to consumer,
retail, online retail.
O'Leary: Randall, I buy that
it works, okay?
You're saying you're going
to make $150,000 this year.
That's a projection, by the way.
After tax, $125,000.
You're asking me to pay 64 times
your profit this year,
if you hit it,
which is still speculative.
Yeah. We ‐‐
Now, you see any problem
with that
that might keep
somebody away at night
regardless of what music
they're listening to?
Frankel: Sounds like a dream.
Sounds like a dream.
A nightmare.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
They're interested in dreampad,
a pillow that aids sleep by
playing music through vibration.
But they want Randall
to defend his steep valuation.
You're saying you're going
to make $150,000 this year.
That's a projection,
by the way.
After tax, $125,000.
You're asking me to pay 64 times
your profit this year,
if you hit it,
which is still speculative.
Yeah. We ‐‐
Now, you see any problem
with that
that might keep
somebody away at night
regardless of what music
they're listening to?
Frankel: Sounds like a dream.
Sounds like a dream.
A nightmare.
We based the value on looking
at the future value.
We've made projections
five years out.
The price you put on it is so,
like, delusional.
Cuban: Randall, Randall,
have you ever seen
a five‐year projection
that was correct?
You're right. It all comes down
to the projections.
You're absolutely right.
And I would ask you,
considering ‐‐
I project you won't
get a deal today
because you have
a crazy valuation.
I would ask you to consider
the key things
that are supporting
the valuation.
‐Which are?
‐Number one, it's patented.
‐So?
‐Number two, it's addressing
an incredible need
within the country.
Agreed.
Number three is it's got
a supply chain
that's completely worked out.
How much have you put
in of your own money?
Over the last five years,
my partner and I
have invested $1.2 million.
All: Wow!
Cuban: Look, Randall.
The challenge I see is that
where there's a specific need,
you've got to be able
to convince people
that you are so far better
than the options...
Right.
...that they're going to make
the investment, right?
‐So...
‐I'm out.
♪♪
Randall, you valuation
is nuts.
‐Nuts.
‐I'm out.
‐Okay, well ‐‐
‐Nuts!
The valuation is from
the planet Zoot Boot.
It makes no sense.
On Zoot Boot, the pay
64 times cash flow.
They have no problem.
The Zootonians will do deals
like this all the time.
I am not a Zootonian.
I'm from the planet Earth.
I'm out.
What are you going
to do, Bethenny?
Frankel: I love this.
I love everything about it.
It's such a lesson to people
to not be so bullish
about their price.
You can't make up numbers and
think someone's going to pay,
'cause you came here for, like,
the greatest opportunity ever.
And I would've been so all‐in.
And I just can't ‐‐ I can't.
It's $800,000.
You know how hard
I work for that?
It's crazy.
And I'm out,
but I'm so frustrated.
I would've been so in.
I'm so aggravated.
‐You got one Shark left.
‐It's just me.
‐Okay, Lori.
‐Just you and me.
I like the quality.
I like the feel.
I've done millions and millions
of dollars in pillows.
I like the concept.
I love everything about it.
I like you.
‐But...?
But $800,000 for 10%?
You don't really know
what's going to happen.
I actually think we could put
your technology into the pillows
I already sell at
a fraction of the price.
Right.
I sell pillows for a third
of the price.
Lori, what are you doing?
So, you tell me.
What would you offer me?
Because I think you need
to be creative here.
♪♪
Well, I've got, you know ‐‐
Obviously, I discussed this
with my partners and stuff
before coming on.
And I've got permission
to go down to 15% ‐‐
go up to 15% for that,
for the $800,000.
That's a valuation
of over $5 million.
Oh, my God. You should be saying
you'll give her 60%.
I mean, honestly, you should be
telling her you'll give her 60%.
‐Randall, it's crazy.
‐No, that's nutballs.
$800,000 for 15%
is your counter?
Randall, I so much want
to be in with you.
‐Yes. Do you?
‐What are you doing, Lori?
Unfortunately,
I have to be out.
‐Okay.
‐Wow.
Randall,
it was a great product.
I wanted to live
the dream.
Randall, I'll meet you
on Zoot Boot.
‐All right. Thank you.
‐It was so nice.
Redfield: I was kind of shocked
that they felt
the valuation was that crazy.
But it's worth
what I'm asking for it.
If anybody here
had done that deal,
I would never speak
to them.
You don't want to get into
a pillow fight with me.
People have gone
to the hospital!
Oh, I'm going to
destroy you, Robert.
Oof!
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a popular
beverage with an attitude.
♪♪
My name is Jenni‐Lyn Williams,
and I am the owner
and creator of Snarky Tea.
I am here seeking $150,000
for 25% stake.
At Snarky Tea,
we aim to keep it real
by creating high‐quality
whole‐leaf tea sachets
that are designed to do exactly
what they say they'll do.
For example, let's say
it's 11:45 p. m.
but you're wide awake.
You found yourself in another
social‐media rabbit hole.
No worries, girlfriend.
Our "Get Your Ass in Bed"
blend
will help you
shut down, unplug,
and get some beauty rest.
Or perhaps your to‐do list
is crazy long,
and adulting feels like
an impossible task.
No worries.
Our "Fierce Bitch" blend
will have you slaying the day
in no time.
So, who's ready to dive
into the Snark Tank
and change the way
this world sees tea?
Cute.
I have hand selected a blend
for each of you
based upon your unique
personalities.
‐All right.
‐So fabulous.
Where did she go?
Oh.
Okay, here we go.
‐Mrs. Wonderful!
‐Look at that.
‐Yeah.
Kevin is married,
I have to say.
‐Kevin!
‐That's okay.
So, the tin on your tray is
the blend that you received.
You'll be able to find out
what the blend's called
by looking inside your card.
‐Hey, girl.
‐Thank you.
‐You got it.
‐Hey, girl.
There you go.
I just need to take off
this jacket.
O'Leary: So, Jenni‐Lyn,
I have a card here
that says "Mr. Wonderful" on
the front and inside it says,
"Blend ‐‐
Calm the [bleep] down.
You're just so handsome
when you smile.
That's true.
"Caribbean rooibos
fruit with coconut"?
‐It's a rooibos tea...
‐Rooibos.
‐...which is great
for inflammation
and hypertension,
so it really does help
you calm the [bleep] down.
Mine says, "Our signature blend
for the person
fierce enough to swim
with the Sharks."
Well, that remains
to be seen.
We believe in you,
Bethenny.
‐TBD.
‐Wow.
We know you can hang.
Are all these blends
for women only?
Yes.
That would leave 50%
of the market untouched.
I became really passionate
about this idea
that I'm not the only
woman out there
who's struggling with trying
to meet all of the expectations
that we kind of
put on women today.
So I took a product
that we also have
a ton of expectations
about, right?
We think of tea as kind of
this gentle, dainty beverage.
But I broke it out of its box.
And in the end, I think it's
really a better representation
of what the drink is.
It's a badass beverage.
‐So it's intentional.
‐Yeah.
Right out of the gate,
you're not going after
half the market.
That's right.
But women are the purchasers
of the household.
When are you
buying tea bags?
I buy them all the time,
actually.
You do?
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Yeah, I do too.
I drink tea. What am I,
chopped liver here?
Let's be clear, right?
You're not selling tea, right?
‐Right.
‐You're selling attitude.
‐Well, we're selling both.
‐Where are you selling this?
So right now, 85% of our sales
are done retail
through our own website.
We do 15% wholesale,
so we're in about 40 stores.
Which stores?
Mostly, like, women‐owned
boutiques and gift shops.
I've heard tea, for many people,
is relaxing.
Yet it's called Snarky
and you're going to alienate
places like Walmart and...
‐Right.
...you know, a lot
of major retailers.
I feel a little confused.
What are your sales?
We've done $190,000
in eight months.
Whoa!
Give us customer
acquisition cost.
So, our cost of acquiring
customer right now is about $11.
How much is this?
So, there are 15 sachets
in each of our tins,
and they're $12.99.
That's expensive, though.
A K‐Cup is 66 cents.
‐Tell us your costs.
‐Okay.
So, each of our tins
actually cost us $4.34 to make.
‐$4.34? That's a lot.
‐Yes.
‐How much do you sell it for?
‐$12.99 a tin.
So you're not making
any money.
Your customer acquisition
costs 11 bucks.
Greiner: Well, listen.
I find that this kind of cute
labeling and all of that,
I'm afraid it's not sustainable.
And gimmicky branding,
I just don't see as long future.
So while I think you are
clever and smart, I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Jenni‐Lyn, I've done very well
by finding niche things...
‐Yes.
‐...like the Tipsy Elves guys,
and expanding them.
I think it's a little too edgy.
‐I ‐‐
It's a very narrow niche.
‐Yes.
I don't see people
buying tins of tea online
as a sole business.
I just don't see it.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
Jenni‐Lyn,
now anything that's sold
in retail
competes with Amazon.
‐I'm on Amazon.
‐Doesn't matter, right?
The challenge is that not only
is Amazon distributing products,
but they're also starting
to create their own...
‐Right.
‐...that are obviously
priced cheaper
than everybody else.
‐Yes.
‐And it's their brand,
so they get to put it
and promote it however
they want in
the easiest‐to‐buy format.
Click it, and it shows up
in two hours.
Yep.
I like what you're doing
from a marketing perspective,
but Amazon's
going to crush you.
I'm out.
This fits on my wedding
platform as a gift, okay?
‐I knew that was coming.
‐Yes.
And we've got a lot
of customers.
‐Right.
‐I'll tell you this.
I could sell a lot of these at a
lower customer acquisition cost.
I know how to make
this company money,
and that's what's
going to matter
'cause that's ultimately
what you want to do...
Yes.
...grow a business
out of a product, okay?
‐Of course.
‐Here's the deal.
I want to be a 50/50 partner.
‐Oh!
‐Silence.
I'll give you $150,000 for 50%.
♪♪
The rest of this is noise.
No, I consider
it a valid offer.
It's noise.
I'm in the coffee
business already.
Then make her an offer.
Stop your squawking.
I'm making the same offer, but
you don't have to deal with him.
You can deal with me,
who happens to be snarky.
Oh! 50%? You're making the same
offer, and you ask for 50‐‐
How greedy can you be?
‐I'm not being greedy.
I have distribution in place
in consumables.
I am in K‐Cups.
We'd have to tone
down the message,
because I don't think you should
limit it just to your website.
It's a good product,
and I think that's totally
lost in the message.
Yep.
But if you could possibly
co‐brand with Skinnygirl,
I might want to consider that if
you would be interested in that.
I'm as snarky as you are,
if not more.
Would you guys
consider partnering?
♪♪
I like your wedding business.
I will say that.
Yes, you do.
All your clients
are my customers.
But we're not reducing
the amount.
I'd do that deal with you,
but I want 50%
of the business
combined so I get 25%.
I've got to have skin
in the game.
I've got to wake up in
the morning and smell the tea.
Jenni‐Lyn, you never give up
50% of your business.
Business 101.
♪♪
Mr. Wonderful, my father
is a used car dealer.
If I didn't counter you
with 42%, he would kill me.
I like 50%. I really do,
especially if I've got to
split mine with ‐‐
I've got to work with this guy?
How 'bout 49%?
No.
Look, we're very good
at making money.
Jenni‐Lyn, if you give 50%,
it's not your company anymore.
‐That's not true.
‐Are you in or out?
I'm just telling you.
I'm trying to help
an entrepreneur,
like I always do.
You're gonna have
to trust your partners
if you're going to get
into business, then.
All right, you guys.
You got a deal.
‐Okay.
‐Wow.
Congratulations, Jenni.
‐Sorry, Mark.
‐Hey.
‐Mrs. Wonderful!
‐She's wearing my colors.
I want to know
if that was intentional.
I was so excited you were
going to be here.
Frankel: I like you.
I'm investing in you.
‐Absolutely.
‐You're awesome.
Are you going to name
the baby Kevin?
‐Absolutely.
‐You should.
She's a bad bitch.
Williams: I love Bethenny.
I love her brand.
I love her personality.
So to have fierce bitches
plus Mr. Wonderful,
I really think we're going
to knock it out of the park.